i've just arrived in india's capital
delhi on the first leg of my great
escape
morning how are you are you well good to
see you
oh
my god it's so hard
is that the air conditioning
[Music]
i want to discover the truth about curry
i know our uk version is nothing like
the real thing
so i want to learn how indian food
should be made
99 of the food in the uk regarding the
curries are all from north india delhi i
don't know if what we're doing the uk is
an insult to what they do over here i'm
not complete with the level of indian
food that i know
delhi
is the eighth largest metropolis in the
world with 17 million residents
my issue is are we doing it wrong
are we faking it
and delhi is going to give me my answer
so my mission in northern india is a
personal culinary voyage of discovery
[Music]
all the classics such as rogue and josh
biryani and butter chicken come from
here
[Music]
in the 19th century workers in the
british raj acquired a taste for curry
creating a demand for it upon the
returns of britain
and we've been in love with indian food
ever since
india is a big mystery to me it's like
the wacky races
unbelievable
i've never been to india before and i
have to say it's quite a shock to the
system
i mean this is extraordinary i mean kids
everywhere people actually living on the
street
i need a bit of guidance i'm on my way
to meet someone who can help at one of
india's most famous restaurants
the moti mahal
it's here uk favorites such as tandoori
chicken were invented
sima chandra is an expert on the food of
northern india and she's helping me with
my travel itinerary hi hello how are you
very well good to see you see my chandra
ah nice welcome to india very happy to
be here she's one of india's most
respected food writers and restaurant
critics why have you brought me here
well the reason i got you here is that
this place
is where most of indian food the way
it's known the world over yeah they all
began here i love milk mahoney the dal
chicken tikka makhani as in butter
chicken yes well butter chicken started
right here 60 years ago seriously is
there a difference between what they're
serving here to what we're serving in
the uk it is
nothing close
what you're going to get i mean i was
shocked that they even call it indian
food in fact i have a problem with it
it's not indian cream and they put sugar
into everything yeah and they think okay
that's it that's done it's not indian
food shall we order so we'd like butter
chicken of course butter chicken
tandoori chicken so you're more
convinced that i'm going to taste a big
difference to what i'm about to
eat out and out
thank you okay yeah thank you are you
going to eat with your
with a knife in front will you tell me
you can't get the flavor of indian food
with a knife and fork no
i should try that back at home it's
glass famous it's blasphemous what do
you think it's absolutely delicious and
it's not um it's not dry it's moist it's
moist here
that's the dish you've been waiting for
so the butter chicken
this is it
bloody hell it is nothing gives me more
pleasure than seeing someone neat and
saying bloody hell
how does this compare with what you have
i mean that already honestly seymour
it's chalk and cheese it's very
flavoursome yeah and there's no
it doesn't taste
taint tartare jelly it's not like it's
been laced with tomato puree not at all
fresh tomatoes i think a working holiday
will show me the real india
i need to go native if i'm truly to
discover how our uk flavors should be
cooked
i'm not here to watch no i would like i
want to cook that's it
okay now the thing is not stay away from
the touristy traps quite the contrary go
into the remote areas right go into
people's homes go into the desert the
best food
is in these little little areas it's not
in fancy places go for the humble go for
the humble get to know what does this do
why is this yellow why is this brown why
is this little thing looking like moss i
think it's really important for gordon
to understand what we indians eat every
day a regular sort of food i'm being
apprenticed under a chef famous for his
intricate dishes and infamous for his
lack of patience
sounds like my kind of man
that's the kitchen
[Music]
hey how are you
good to see you are you well you're very
well good excited to be here yeah hi we
were just expecting you everything oh
well i got here early yeah how are you
fight good to see you okay excellent
head chef imtiaz qureshi was born into
the dynasty of bowaches his five sons
including irfan my translator are all
chefs too
79 years old he's 79 today he's got a
handshake like a 25 year old in england
they call you king korma
yes in england this man's reputation is
called the dog's bollocks
yeah the dog's nuts
number one
yes definitely gonna explain him how
old's your father my father is around
1848 84. it's gone up in the last five
minutes that's amazing so what's the
first thing we're gonna do for today the
first we'll do the the marination of
dumba biryani okay in the uk the biryani
is often a bland dish stodgy rice with
frozen veg and a tasteless sauce
but it's soon clear the complex dumber
biryani is going to be nothing like the
dole uk version
i would really enjoy if i could do it
that's what i'm trying to tell him like
you just give it to him he's like me a
control freak
this is uh videga yes i've never seen
two whole goats in a biryani before
first i'm tenderizing them with vinegar
then they'll be stuffed with chickens
quails and eggs and served on a bed of
fragrant rice okay okay yeah
okay oh out jesus thank you okay
now we're coating the goats in ginger
and chili
you just five five
okay like that mtr's makes it clear that
great indian cookery is instinctive
there's no recipe as such
you know what he's trying to say
whenever the new student comes and you
try to learn so you should respect the
the teacher you know i definitely
respect the teacher trust me he looks
like kind of guy i don't want to fall
out with okay
in terms of technique this dish is as
complex as anything in michelin style
cookery
i'm now marinating the chicken and the
quails in the chili ginger garlic and
yogurt mix
what is a basic takeaway in britain is a
finely tuned feasting dish in india
back in the uk
every curry house
99 of them use the same base for the
sauce here it's completely different
individual curry individual sauce
there's no same base it's all becoming
so much clearer
[Music]
enough yeah i think it's perfectly okay
what's the largest wedding your father's
ever cooked
[Music]
uh he's saying almost fifty thousand to
one lakh equalized and
uh fifty thousand oh my god oh
my god
people from all over the world from
president to and minister to
they always
cater to everyone
empty ours has got a bigger head than me
but i would love to have the chance to
work for him you know when he was a
rottweiler
under the age of 35.
yeah but look at the hands they're like
shovels look
oh my god
amazing
amazing amazing mate 84 as strong as an
ox his father was almost 135 years old
his father was 135 years old yeah jesus
the one thing into interiors isn't
bullshitting about is the food
the hard-boiled eggs are coated in
saffron
egg inside the quail
i haven't had a master class like this
since my tommy chef days in paris that
way
jesus
the eggs go inside the quail the quail
inside the chicken and finally we stuff
it all in the goats
it's almost like sort of
rewinding giving birth
yeah you're putting it back in once it's
been born
we're going to stitch it wow
it was a dish that was put together for
why
right
this this dish was made for only for a
king
don't light it down just make him stand
i'll stand them up
very good
this show beats a supermarket curry
ready meal
the goats have been left to cook for
three hours
old boy empty house he's a he's a legend
no one knows his age but he's a hard ass
trust me you don't want to mess with him
more importantly he doesn't speak a word
of english but we're communicating
through the food taste understanding but
what a technical genius way of putting
together a goat biryani
the final stage is the rice for the
biryani
first we clean and part ball basmati
rice
so the rice is cooked with
a bag of
sort of aromatic spices
so it's like a bokeh garlic
[Music]
now i'm learning the technique known as
dumb cooking the rice is placed in a
special pan and saffron is added
then the pan is sealed with pastry and
the rice is left to steam
but one small mistake can mean disaster
know saffron
time to put on the pastry seal but it's
not happening quick enough for emptiers
what's wrong
[Laughter]
huh
in situations like this you keep your
mouth shut and finish the job quickly
the whole style behind dumbbell cooking
is keeping all the flavors locked in so
sealing with the pastry on the outside
is that little sort of work of magic
so how long for that now
i think it will take uh 25 minutes
we've been cooking all day
and the first guests are starting to
arrive
time to assemble adam biryani
[Music]
you gonna pick this yeah
[Music]
the biryani is finished with spicy
indian meatballs called kofta
coriander and dried apricot
amazing ask him for the first time this
morning is he happy with it
good excellent at the beginning i felt
like a bit of a spare prick at a wedding
10 minutes into it he made me feel like
a chef thank
that's you delicious
refined wine if he was living in britain
for the last 84 years
would have a completely different take
on indian food you know that i don't
know
i swear to god it's
delicious
authentic and amazing